costco nike and fedex are warning
there's more inflation said to it
consumers that holiday approaches the
nbc story
costco nike and fedex are not
politicians they're not democrats or
republicans costco has joined the long
list of retailers sounding the alarm
about escalating shipping prices and
accompanying supply chain issues the
warehouse retailer was joined by
athletic wear giant nike and economic
belt weathers uh uh fedex and general
mills in discussing similar concerns the
cost to ship containers overseas has
soared in recent months getting a
40-foot container from shanghai to new
york cost two thousand dollars a year
and a half ago before kovit you know
what it is right now sixteen thousand
dollars let me say this one more time
yeah so costco nike and fedex saying
guys i'm sorry we have to raise our
prices people like what are you no
you're not going to raise your prices no
no i don't think you understand these
containers when we get our stuff from
shanghai used to cost only two grand
we're paying eight times more today
16 grand a pop the cost includes not
only freight but also higher labor costs
rising demand for transportation and
products plus shortages and computer
chips oils chemicals and higher
commodity prices we can't uh we can't
hold on to all of those
some of that has to be passed on to who
to us
and it is being passed on we're
pragmatic about it said costco cfo
reached richard gallanty so basic
mathematics here you just tell what's
going on so you're asking the question
pat what is it what is this so different
bro it's not a little bit of inflation
if something increased from 2 million to
you know if something can increase from
10 bucks to 12 bucks what do you say
yeah whatever if something you're buying
normally goes from 10 bucks to 15 bucks
what do you say dude that's a little
weird wouldn't you say that like think
about what you buy every month imagine
if the gym membership's 50 bucks a month
do you complain no imagine next 124 our
fitness says it's gonna be 75 bucks next
month now let me give you a different
one imagine 24 hour fitness all of a
sudden says
we know your membership's been 50 a
month for the last 10 years effective
next month is 400 bucks a month
that's just what happened to these guys
how sustainable is that
what do you where else do you get it
from
and china guess what china's going to
say don't get it from us
don't go elsewhere where do you go
well as a consumer we have the option to
say well sorry uh no you don't know
i'm not getting it but you don't have to
you don't have you're not gonna have the
option do you know why you're not gonna
have the option here's why you're not
gonna have the option okay put two
things that we can com companies that
compete against each other mcdonald's
burger king
gold starbucks uh what's the other one
coffee bean okay i would put mcdonald's
versus dunkin donuts because the
coffee's about the same price right okay
so
say i'm toyota say i'm ford your gm
and i say
oh man dude this just we gotta frickin
do something you know let's raise the
price is 30 percent your ford what do
you say
we're gonna stake to the same prices
okay cool do it
one month goes by two months goes by
three months two quarters three quarters
your cfo comes in
uh remember how you wanted to report
your earnings and you wanted ebitda to
be higher we have depleted our cash this
much in the last three quarters you sure
you don't want to raise the prices
oh then the boy have a board meeting uh
ceo of ford listen we're looking at the
numbers and the profits in the last
three quarters and we haven't risen
prices but gm has and chrysler has
what are we going to do to raise prices
to match our competitors and you're the
ceo what do you say i don't think it's
fair are you kidding me the ceo's going
to say
okay
all right so the regular afford focus
that was 22 000 is now
29 000
who feels it
so there is you you don't have the
choice anymore adam
you don't have another alternative it's
the illusion i try to look at it from a
consumer's perspective hear me out yeah
okay other than saving your money or
investing and having a better asset
allocation plan yeah what the hell are
you going to do about it nothing
it is what it is what do you mean no no
what do you mean you as a consumer if
inflation collection other than save
your money and really smart with your
money and invest wisely what else are
you going to do
really bro okay so uh how many people go
to costco
millions of people how many people ship
stuff
how many people use fedex how many
people ship it a lot okay
you don't have a choice but have that
being felt that's my point it's like all
right it is what it is i have no say
over this inflation of course you don't
have sex exactly what's your point
though that's my point is that it is
what it is
other than being smart with your money
it works because you know what comes
what do you mean it is what it is bro
you know what comes next the dollar gets
weaker it's still the strongest currency
in the world the dollar gets weaker the
economy takes a hit
people are out there not knowing how to
make an income more division amongst
everybody then you have more protesting
then you have more rights then what the
hell do you do
this is what comes next this is not
sustainable to go like this
you cannot have fake success for too
long bro listen name any bodybuilder
there was a guy on youtube that was had
a youtube channel million and a half
subscribe i don't remember his name but
pena piana piano some some name like
that and he was everywhere and he said
for 20 years i've been straight on
steroids and growth hormone
for 20 years he said that for 20 years
and he did a video he says my hand used
to be this big now it's this big i used
to be size 11 shoes now i'm 13 and a
half my hat used to be seven now it's
eight and a half whatever he ex tells
you exactly my heart used to be this
size he's this size you know what
happened to him three years ago four
years ago what do you think happened to
him
guy passed away
cool-looking guy spoke very well was
very elegant passed away
you cannot have fake testosterone for
your entire life and you're overdosing
on it
america's had fake steroids growth
hormone for
how many how long have we been at zero
interest rate at the number that we're
less than one percent
america's been on steroids and growth
hormone for so long that the moment you
get off of it when you get off the
stairs your skin gets yellow because
your body forgot how to produce
testosterone when america gets off of
this all growth hormone and steroids
america's economy is not going to know
how to reproduce it it's going to take a
while this is not like a
another 01 or 008 no we're not talking
about another 0 108 this is catastrophic
and the fact that michael bury has the
audacity to go out there and talk about
this stuff more freaking power to him
it's forcing us to have the conversation
it's
for somebody to actually make you
question
that inflation is not there no no no no
no and powell
you you're not talking about lightweight
yelling
people like that that are saying no this
is normal notice what the hell do you
mean this is normal it's not normal
lying through the teeth
but but but it's not i don't think it's
the
lying through the
teeth because i think that's not a
republican democrat thing i think
everybody's lying through their teeth i
think it's more the following i think
here's what it is okay
i think it's more from the standpoint of
i look at it
i think the president i think it's from
the standpoint of the following thing do
your parents lie to you
yeah for how long
let me ask you a question my whole life
is for your own good is it good that
your parents lie to you
think about the question right there it
tends to what they're lying about white
lies whatever i don't know let me ask
you a question you're four years old
mommy how are babies or babies or babies
are born is it good for your mom to tell
you exactly how babies are born probably
not at that probably not they're lying
to you though right parents
do you think it's good to say uh santa
claus is fake at three years old to a
kid no
but you're lying yeah parents are liars
okay fine
but you lied to me at three fine true
fourth spell fine
if you're lying to me at 38 right what
the hell are we doing
i understand yelling lion i understand
there's a part of it but dude this is no
longer a time to lie you have to come up
and say we have an issue america here's
what we need to start doing save the
freaking money
kick back a little bit okay chill out
with the spending habits let's kind of
change some of these habits that we have
no more talking to american adults as if
they're four year olds you're scared
shitless whether they're gonna believe
in santa claus anymore tell them the
damn truth i'm 40 years old santa
doesn't exist
tell me he doesn't exist tell me some of
these things here it's time for me to
know and these guys are treating adults
as if they're kids no inflation is gonna
hit us
this is not something that's fake this
is not something that's just the
rhetoric they're lying because they
think they're protecting us right and
that's their that's their whole motive
and what's gonna happen when all these
things all these things do happen the
global shipping crisis you're gonna
watch the christmas shopping this year
wait till you see what you're not being
able to get wait till you see how much
your nike shoes are getting jacked up
this is all real i'll tell you another
thing um i can see
any day six of these huge
tankers or these huge vessels that carry
all the goods from china i can see them
every day from my deck with binoculars
they're out there i don't know if
they're coming in and they can't get in
or if they've unloaded in their head and
back i've never seen it before but if
you look at these aerial images of long
beach or even in new york there's 80
ships waiting a month to unload all this
stuff is going to happen so when you and
then they think they could just put a
band-aid on it with 3.5 trillion dollars
and just keep paying money but who are
we going to blame when this all does
all the [ __ ] does hit the fan with
inflation with you're going to the
grocery store and things aren't there
and and you can't order things on amazon
that you're used to will they blame the
democrats and if and if it coincides
with a market crash will that
mitch would that be the impetus to get
people out mitch mcconnell is just as
much at fault for this as any democrat
number one number two i think the big
difference here guys and you both made
really really good points the big
difference is here your parents lie to
you because they love you
you know they want to protect you
these politicians are lying to us
because they think we're stupid and they
want to protect themselves and they want
to protect they want to protect their
jobs and they want to protect their
their their q score they want to protect
their chance at re-election are your
parents live for your own good
politicians lie for their own good and
that's something that needs to be
understood
brutally knows
when you were talking about the fact
that this is kind of like an engineered
crisis they're not hiding that this is
from march of last year this is the
majority whip the house majority whip
the number two democrat in the entire
congress okay tim clybourn this is when
kovid was raging everything was just
getting shut down we had no idea we
thought that this was the black plague
still okay new york was completely empty
his response is
the coronavirus is a tremendous
opportunity to restructure things to fit
our vision
this has been played out guys for 18
months
this is not new as soon as this thing
happened all right as soon as this thing
happened
people in power saw this and said okay
open the piggy bank let's get our let's
do you want the green new dill here it
is what do you need who are our donors
let's get it to them right here and they
didn't lie about it this was one of the
times where they said the quiet part out
loud the coronavirus is a chance to fit
this one i mean
i get that and by the way listen
both sides are opportunistic and what
they're doing both sides are
opportunistic you have to know well one
side is wanting to put the more the onus
on you the other side wants to
put the onus on rich people so one is
saying look you can do something about
your life the other side is saying no
poor you you can't do anything about
your life you're a victim let us help
save you right one is trying to be your
hero the other one's trying to say why
don't you do something about yourself
because when you win you feel better
about yourself when you accomplish
something you feel good about yourself
what happened when you won a game you
felt good about yourself what happened
when you got that job and you got a
promotion you felt good about yourself
what happened when you got you know
first ten thousand dollars in a bank you
felt good about yourself what happened
when you bought your first car without
needing mommy and daddy you felt good
about yourself this is all confidence
boosting opportunities right that we
have
one side saying no you don't understand
you are a victim
you you're not as smart as them we we
know what we're doing we know what's
best for you the other side is saying i
believe in you i think you're capable
why don't you go do something about it
let's go and and i think you can pull
this off let's see what you got how bad
do you want it it's a different level of
coaching on what you got
so i'm not surprised that this is taking
place all i'm saying is when it comes
down to the numbers right now what we're
talking about adam this is not the same
thing here
when was this the speech that he gave
march 2022.
march 2020 23rd yeah okay so trump was
still president republicans still
controlled the senate at that point
trump you know one thing that i love
about republicans is they'll talk about
lo you know
not spending as much lowering the
deficit balancing the budget and then
they don't [ __ ] do it
like trump spent as much money and
yeah with stimulus as any democrat ever
so
rhetoric is
rhetoric is one thing and then what they
actually do is another stop who has to
pass it
who has to pass the stimulus house okay
and send control and the president has
to sign up who control them who control
the house
democrats had the house republicans had
the senate and trump was president at
the time of this story so what does he
do at a point like that
the point listen this isn't a debate he
passed it no no no but it's not about he
passed it do you remember how they
create a climate for it to be passed so
fine now go there do you think at the
time when he passed it it was necessary
they held the company
now i'm asking you do you think at the
time it was necessary to pass it
in hindsight yes yeah okay do you think
it's necessary today to do three and a
half trillion dollar bill i don't know
it just seems like a lot of printing of
the money like to your point okay so so
it's a slippery slope so so but
you're basically trying to say like i
don't know what your intention was
but at the time of this speech that
reinvent the wheel when you get the
podcast did we support it
did we do the podcast in march of 20
when we were talking about it did we
support it
do we support it i think it was we had
an open forum debate about it yeah we
like hey let's go out there and spend
all the money was i for printing money
no not at all am i a guy that's saying
let's keep printing money and keep give
money away to people no no but if you
shut me down and i'm california and i
can't get out you don't have the right
to shut me now without paying me yeah do
you understand what i'm saying like hey
you can't come to work i'm sorry bro
what do you want me to do
i have to take care of my family at
least pay me we have to pay you you
can't do one without the other
because if you do and if they don't pay
remember with the conversation we had
with they said if they don't pass this
year what do you think is going to
happen in the streets people are going
to find a way to get their money how to
get to get their money remember there
was like a three month period where
people were worried on the streets
what's going to be happening you don't
remember the crime was up breaking into
houses do you forget those stories so
you can't corner one side and put people
in their houses and tell them you can't
get out and not have to make that move
that's not the case today but today they
want to do more than they did a year a
year ago my point is this do democrats
not know how to balance budget the last
time we had a balanced budget was under
bill clinton let's not forget that yeah
the last time we had a balance budget
dude what okay what sure what part of
let's not let's not pretend republicans
don't spend money too what part of this
conversation is left or right what part
of this conversation is left to right i
think gerard's point was that it was a
large point as a difference that's my
point my point on this was that this
isn't a market correction that we're
hearing this isn't a market correction
that we're living through my whole point
of bringing this up isn't democrat
republican it's the fact that this isn't
a market correction against you know uh
uh free money in the marketplace or or a
derivative problem this is a government
created
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye
[Music]